my name is Heidi Hernandez I work for a
word from research south american team
but what i am presenting here today is
part of a project I've developed outside
of work in my University back in Peru
they are actually building a
computerized tool to assess male
fertility based on analyzing videos and
images from sperm samples so what I did
in the early stages of the project was
like a brief research and using
Mathematica develop model to analyze the
morphology of the sperm cell head
specifically as a partial result on the
evaluation of the sale so this is what
I'm going to show you today first of all
and the analysis of the sperm cells
involves concentration motility analysis
and morphological classification and
there is also a microscopic analysis
that's made samples but I mean in terms
of the microscopic analysis this is what
what usually it's done nowadays the
methods used to evaluate sperm
morphology are mostly manual unlike
objectivity and for a computerized tools
that does exist and there is criticism
about the high costs they have they are
difficult to calibrate mostly they are
hard to make to use in a lot of cases so
the goal of this project in particular
was to develop a computational model to
characterize the morphological aspects
of the sperm cells and tracked features
and classification of these cells head a
normal or abnormal using machine
learning algorithm so we use two sources
I used to two sources the first of those
were made available in the center of
details per milligram assisted by
Internet
she's some organization from Chile I am
not including the images in the
presentation where I do have some notes
at the end on the reference so where if
you are interested in knowing more about
this you can find the images there so
this is an example of the images we get
from the first source and then from the
second source was the work health health
organization laboratory manual we get
these other images that we needed to use
to sources because the first one wasn't
didn't contain enough cells and also the
cells were mostly abnormal and that
doesn't work if you want to build a
machine learning model you need
representation for for both of the
classes normal or abnormal cells that
was the reason we had to use a second
source so for both sources and we had
the images and we also had a
classification made by the specialists
whether the cells were normal or not so
we could train the machine learning
algorithm so we needed mineralized
images for this original images so we
could analyze the components in this
case the sperms sales head so in the
case of the first group of images we we
had those mineralized masks for each of
the of the images so in that case we
were good but for the second source we
didn't have those so we had to do one
extra processing to obtain the winner
ice mask so Mathematica had tools to do
to do that the thing is that they cannot
be directly used for I mean they doesn't
work directly for all of the cases you
need to do some calibration on the
parameters and in this case for example
this is an example image from the second
source and the bitter eyes function from
mathematical which is what what we use
what it does is that it transform the
image to a grayscale and then apply some
algorithm with by default this Otsu
algorithm to separate the foreground and
the background of the image and return
the binary image which only contains
black and white pixels so internally the
winner eyes function has have to find a
threshold value but we find out that the
value that it's finding by default mates
the result something like this which is
not what we wanted because there is a
lot of information that it's not what we
need so the first thing could be to
adjust select the components with a
salad components tool in this case by
the area filtering by the area so we
just use the components that have a size
that we know where we are looking for
and we get rid of some white points that
are in that space but that is not enough
again so what we did was we try to find
an adequate value for the threshold in
this case and we we didn't begin from
the front 0 we look around the threshold
value that mathematically returns and we
look in the neighborhood of tow of that
value so here there is an example of
what happens if we use a small value of
the threshold we lose information on the
sales head and if we use a larger value
than we are including information that
is not wanted so the key here was to
find an adequate threshold value so this
is an example of the of one of the
results obtained images and not be so
I'm kind enough so with this procedure
we were able to identify almost ninety
eight percent of the of the sales in the
second source which for the purposes of
the investigation was of the research
was a good result so
the next step is to extract the feature
mathematica have the component
measurements function which works with
binary images and measure features from
the from the components in the in the
image so in this case for example for
the very image we we have I've just I'm
not showing what Mathematica doesn't
mean it doesn't does that that directly
I just draw the bounding box to see that
it's actually identifying in a really
good way the head cells which is what we
want and then once we are sure we are
actually identifying what we want we can
measure those components and I'm showing
in the data set in this case we are
using length with area perimeter
eccentricity and radio something that I
didn't mention before is that there is
no consensus about what are the features
that must be used to characterize the
sperm and head sale head so what we did
is we use some of the ones that are more
mentioned and that have been obtained
good results with and also we added the
eccentricity and radio just to give the
idea that the sperm cell head must have
around and regular a regular shape so it
there are some additional steps here
first of all we need to add a label to
each of the of the entities in this case
the sperms sale head we needed to add
the correct the classification given by
the specialists where the cell was
normal or not so we could train the
classifier and we also we also needed to
convert the pixels of the measurements
to to make micrometer sank for that
purpose we use a factor for each of the
sources with was given in the
documentation of the sources so by doing
that we could generate the data for all
the images all the cells and
at the end we get something we got a
dollar 422 sales 155 normal and 275 and
65 67 abnormal so what we did was
converting that to the machine learning
format for Mathematica which is the
features pointing to the to the value
that of the class in this case 0 for
normal cells one for abnormal cells now
go into the classification step here we
use the word vector machines for those
who are not from familiar with the
algorithm I'm not going to go deep on
that just that to mention that that is a
statistical approach to machine learning
because what we do here is that we have
a set of features to characterize the
entities in this case the sperms sale
head and then we have an algorithm that
compute that but that build a model a
machine learning model based on that
features so the ball break vector
machines are widely use along by
automatic applications because only have
high levels of accuracy and application
similar to the one we were handling in
this project and it also have a good
ability to have a multi-dimensional data
and so on we did a previous step here
before draining the classifier which was
is the standardization of data using the
satellite function from Mathematica so
we give the same opportunities to all
the features regardless of the numeric
value and also that produces a lot of
the loss of information due to numeric
operations so we standardize the
features and then we did principal
component analysis why we did this and
mostly that's used to reduce
dimensionality of the problems in this
case that wasn't a goal at the beginning
because we just have six features so
there was also really not need to
reduce the dimensionality as a
computational problem but the thing is
that this also helps the modded data to
be in a feature space which is more
adequate in the sense that shows better
the relations between the features and
the class and we could eliminate
redundant data maybe some some features
are a combinational other combination of
features so with principal components we
removed that then there was another
question which was which was how many
components to use I'm not going to go
much detail of this but basically what
we did was perform several tests we
using support vector machines with a
default parameters and and then we use
first one component than two component
in three components and and then we see
that with two companies we gained a lot
of accuracy in the results but more than
that is just not doing things any better
so maybe with three components was a
good enough decision to make in the
principal component function of
Mathematica again what it does is that
it won't transform an input matrix in in
its principal component matrix we have
the same day same dimension but we have
independent columns that are order from
left to right in order of variances so
if you want a three first principal
components we just grabbed the first
three columns of the matrix which is
what we did here so for the algorithm we
first have to choose the colonel type
the most popular kernels from SB ms are
linear polynomial radial basis function
we did some tests or the training data
with default parameters for svm some we
obtained that the radial basis function
was such actually giving the best
results and also I mean using radial
basis function is you is generally a
good choice in general because
it handles well nonlinear relations
between data it may behave similarly
that the linear can for some perhaps
ports for some parameters so it's
generally good choice now for each
kernel type there are several parameter
values to be selected for SVM's so in
the case of the radial basis function
kernel which is what what what we use we
have to calibrate the penalty factor C
and the kernel parameter gamma the
strategy used here was a grid search
considering different pairs of C and
gamma and then evaluating the results to
do this we did two steps and the first
one is a loose grid search in which we
use wider intervals and then we plot the
results in here to see what areas were
the ones were better result were
obtained and then in the second step
fine grid search we will went a closer
to that intervals and then we choose
some values for the parameters and have
to say here that these values are not
Michael numbers or anything they depend
on the data we have for for draining so
if you have a different images data sets
so you have to run again this test to
find the numbers that fits best the
specific problem then the we run several
tests or data separating the data on
training and test data randomly and we
found that the we obtain an mean
accuracy of almost seventy-three percent
so to get all the things together just
have a final example here once we have
doing all the step down all the steps
and we have a trainer trainer classifier
which is a classifier function for which
we know the parameters that give the
best results
we can have an image and then a binary
image in this case and then we can apply
the model what is going to happen behind
scenes is that this image is going to be
measured by component measurements these
measures are going to be converted from
pixels so micrometers they are going to
the day that is going to be standardized
it's going to be principal component
analysis on the under the three most
important components selected and
finally using a classifier function that
we have generated up here we are going
to classify these cells and what we are
obtaining here is well we'll have it
here I'm sorry I must forgot to evaluate
something here just one minute
okay here we have and what we get is a
data set and this is just to show the
result of the model of what we were
developing and so we have all the
features with extracted from the images
the actual class and the predicted class
and we can see the relation of that with
the actual image by enumerated in the
cells so we can see that for example
number eight is normal and was correctly
predicted as normal that sells over here
and so on so one final thought I want to
say here is that I was able to use
Mathematica throughout the process from
the basic image processing with it to
the classification part going through
other steps that were complementary to
this work like standardizing the data
doing principal component analysis and
so on by writing minimal amount of code
and having everything in the same place